foreign
hello and welcome to a special episode
of spectator TV I'm Kate Andrews the
spectator's economics editor and I'll be
your host for the next hour staying on
top of your personal finances has never
been easier anyone can buy and sell
stocks at the top of their phone screen
but does smart technology necessarily
mean better safer and easier planning
decisions and while fintech development
has opened up a world of opportunities
what tools are out there for the less
digitally Savvy to discuss all this with
me and more I'm joined by Charlotte
Croswell who is a fintech specialist and
currently the chair and Trustee of open
Banking and I'm also joined by Matt
conrady who is the client advisory at
net wealth and a big thank you to net
well for sponsoring today's episode
so Matt let's jump in and I think you
know some of our audience out there uh
today is is going to be well versed in
this area but others are going to be
relatively new to the topic so can you
break down for us exactly what fintech
is yes of course okay so I mean I think
fintech is a wide-reaching term that
covers a whole host of different areas
essentially it's the combination of
finance and technology so when we think
about that that can mean a host of
things it could be in say payments where
technology is really coming to drive
down the costs of of that process maybe
it's currency conversion in wealth
management technology is really playing
a role in more conventional ways might
be using video to access people around
the country or perhaps we're using it
for modeling and helping people to
understand different outcomes in
retirement but it's a real range of
things at the other end of the spectrum
you've got some new digital type assets
as well so people will be aware of
things like Bitcoin and so on that can
be can be put into those areas but I
think in general we should be thinking
about it's how technology can help drive
forward adoption drive down costs as
well for people in the future and that's
really the role that fintech has to play
and what we should be thinking about it
in that area rather than perhaps the the
edges of the the space and can you talk
to us a little bit about some of those
possibilities that fintech has brought
to wealth management that previously
simply wouldn't have been possible yeah
so so I think you know the pandemic was
a really interesting area where not only
new technologies got started using but
also where the industry was forced to
move forwards as well so videos I think
is a really good example you had
advisors that would only ever meet
people face to face I would not only
sign documents digitally I'm sorry
physically and now suddenly they're
using things like DocuSign or they're
using Zoom or teams to have their
meetings and catch-ups and what they
found was they could be more efficient
and if they can be more efficient in
time they should be able to deliver
their service at a lower cost which is
better for everyone in wealth management
the other thing where we find
particularly net wealth is helping
people understand the decisions they're
making visualizing things and this
engages more people lots of people are
completely turned off by Finance there's
all this jargon that advisors we're all
guilty you know where to start yeah
exactly so you need to start in ways
that engage a little bit more so that
might be using a chart that can build up
over time to show a range of outcomes to
people so they can make more informed
decisions in the past what happened is
advisor would say look let me help you
I'll deal with it leave it over there
that's that's I'll deal with it and you
come back and check in every now and
again now people want more information
at their fingertips and they can make
more informed decisions about that and I
think that's where we should be using
technology it's not about replacing
humans and using algorithms for
everything it's about helping those
humans that you are working with to be
more efficient and those that wanted to
gain more information themselves to have
more access to that information it's
what the internet did in the first place
give us more access to more more things
and this is just another layer of that
over time well I want to come back to
humans versus AI in the fintech theory
but first Charlotte can you talk to us
in terms of that issue of accessibility
can you talk to us a bit more about how
fintech is helping people with their
personal finances yeah and and this is
what it's all about you know it's when
you say somebody what's what is fintech
for most people and I live in central
London most people won't even know what
finte is is and that's a great thing
because you don't need to understand
what fintech is to be using fintech and
to benefit from it and there's a really
good chance that you don't know
um you know it's a bit like when you
when you have when you held your online
cab you don't need to understand the API
that goes from that to the payments
thing that gets you that cab and you've
already secured the payment you just
don't need to know about it you seem to
get from a to be yeah that's it so I
think we have to be careful that we
don't use all of these these acronyms
and Jog and that people sit and get
scared by and then don't use it because
actually what fintech's there to do is
make the customer Journey easier it's
amazing for the end consumer and for
small business and then to sit there and
help to digitize for large businesses
the banks the large financial
institutions to make it easier for them
to Outsource the technology what doesn't
need to be done by humans and perhaps
keep the humans for for when you do need
that more personal touch and it's what
it does is obviously it gives
information at people's fingertips uh
that was saying we've got to sit there
um and make people realize why savings
is important you know how they can use
technology to help them through that
process and maybe they do want to speak
to someone one day and maybe they want
to use technology another day but it's
really for me about making your
financial services Journey easier faster
more efficient more accessible so that
you get a better deal for your finances
and fintech was really born from 2008
from the financial crisis there'll be
lots of companies saying no no I've been
a fintech for 200 years I hear it all
the time
but actually it was really born from
that when we saw more more desire for
more transparency more competition but
as obviously the credit crunch is coming
in a better deal for your finances right
and that doesn't matter if you're right
you know it really suffering from the
poverty premium all the way up to you
know the wealthy the wealthy individuals
nobody gets the best deal for their
finances not anybody not myself not
anyone in this room you know it's
actually about you know helping people
to understand it and it is a journey so
that every single penny and every pound
that they have they're making it used to
the best of the best person well to pick
up on that point about transparency to
what extent do you think we can trust
these algorithms and this technology to
make complex decisions about our
personal finances and actually is it
making decisions for us or is it simply
enabling us to have more access to
information to make those decisions
and I think we have to be we have to
recognize there are going to be flaws in
the system right
um and you know we're here three of us
here today we've got two women generally
there is you know those are often bias
in the system unfortunately against
women we've seen this because there's
been some very high profile cases
um where AI is being used to
predetermine what they think a woman's
credit score should be perhaps versus
their husband somebody's got a joint
account and yeah we saw this with with
instances where the Apple card was
launched where people married joint
accounts everything was done jointly and
sat there the woman was being offered 10
10 times less than a husband in terms of
their credit limit and I think it's made
us religious it is it is because it's
often looking at past data and that's
the problem when you're using past data
to predict the future and then you're
not stopping and saying hold on have we
got this right so again the human
element then we've got to be really
careful because that is going to build
more bias into the system as we go
forward not take it away
um so I think that's the concern we all
have have with AI that we've got to
question it we've got to use it for its
bestability but we've got to have that
Common Sense approaching is this right
why is it giving us those answers and do
we need to take a stop and pause to make
sure there's not any type of
discrimination in the system so we make
sure it's fair for all and then we're
building on the right data rather than
building on poor data and that's nodding
Along come on in Matt yeah well I think
as well that's completely the one of the
challenges and I think it also is
important that we make sure that we use
technology in the right spaces at the
right times technology isn't the answer
to absolutely every problem it's not
going to be the Panacea for everything
and I think what we've realized for
example when we think about wealth
management is there are Parts where
humans even if the technology got it
right removed all the human biases and
presented the information the human then
interpreting that the client the
individual won't believe it as much as
if a human says it back to them and that
they need that support that that element
and what we need to be careful of is
that a few bad experiences don't people
lose complete trust in technology as a
whole so we hear of these these issues
and when we need to correct them perhaps
that's because we're not ready to do
that yet so if we think about Investment
Management where we do planning and
Investment Management we use technology
to help about planning but the
investment management part will use a
human team because we don't think the
algorithm can make that decision it's
always going to be using historic data
it's not going to factor in it
incorrectly and it's certainly not going
to give a better outcome and it probably
won't reassure our clients as much as if
a human is sitting there and dealing
with it so I think it's about finding
that balance not saying we're going all
the way over here to technology doing
everything and saying that we're going
to just let's just start with dealing
some of the really simple problems it's
only recently for example in banking and
because of things like open finance that
you get a notification of your payment
straight away it used to take two days
for a payment to appear in your bank
account let's solve those simple
problems that's got nothing to do with
someone working out what your credit
score is
so I we're going to come back to the
biases built into the system as said
we're definitely coming back to the the
human element here but we actually have
some questions submitted even before we
sat down together and people uh can
submit questions now if they're tuning
in just a reminder to our audience at
home or in the office there is a big
text box on spectator TV you can submit
your questions we'll get them in real
time and I'll put as many as I can to
our panel but one of the questions that
came in uh before we sat down today was
about privacy and about questions around
the algorithms and and Matt that this
person writing and said what about my
privacy how can I be sure that fintech
companies aren't selling off all of my
data so to points about transparency and
people being very cautious these days
about what's shared what would you say
to that so I think security data is one
of the big challenges that you need to
be aware of as a company like like a
wealth or any new startup that's
something that they're going to have on
their risk register it's going to be the
biggest thing they're thinking of
because it basically destroys your brand
if you have a breach it's game over in
this kind of business so there is a lot
of focus on it there's a lot of effort
that goes into that area that's
different though to someone selling on
your data because that's that's a
deliberate delivery of that data and you
need to be aware of checking in for that
making sure that happens you need to
understand what the business's business
model is if you're getting something for
free free trading free things it's not
for free someone's making money
somewhere and are they making it from
selling on your data you need to
understand these business models and
make sure you're comfortable with that
setup I don't think in a regulated world
it's as big a risk as in in some of the
social media areas or so on where
they're lacking that regulation but you
need to be aware of it and you need to
make sure that you're dealing with firms
that take that really seriously so again
on the scale of fintech you have the the
three guys in a room Who start something
and we need some of those because they
drive Innovation and so on but you also
have big businesses that I've got really
stable systems in places that will make
sure you're protected from that and I
think we shouldn't conflate the two and
get concerned about those those
different parts yeah Charlotte do you
worry about completion there and and
also is do you understand the concerns
of people at home when they start
putting some very personal details say
in into an app on their phone about
their financial situation about you know
their home address and all the rest of
it that people might start getting a
little bit nervous about how much
they're handing over I mean I think yeah
it's the biggest issue we have is how do
we bring technology into the 21st
century but give people that trust in
the data as you said data breach is very
different to what are you giving away
right you know so many people have been
said to me oh I won't you know I won't
pay by I won't pay by credit card you
know I don't want to do that I don't
want to put my credit card number into
into a website
here that same person will use a
comparison website to go and perhaps
renew them insurance and we'll give away
everything where they live their age
their marital status you know what their
what their income is and then guess what
a year later they're getting bombarded
about 20 30 providers who are sitting
there saying I understand your insurance
is coming up for Renewal would you like
to talk to us
um so I think it's about an education of
what are you giving away and where where
is it going
um there was the data Reform Bill was is
due to come in it did make it into the
queen speech
um and I think that's incredibly
important because what's that's going to
allow is to give people the the
ownership of their data and ownership of
what they want it to be used for but
importantly when it comes back to them
right you know lots of people talk about
what happens to my data after I die and
it's not such a crazy question because
what is happening with their data you
don't unfortunately it's not like you
know someone goes into your estate and
and sort of you know I've never thought
about it
but can you imagine yeah you don't and
you don't yeah your data is still and
it's still Somewhere Out There in the
cloud so we've got to be very careful
that we allow people to give that away
so they get a better deal for for
financial services and their daily lives
and it becomes easier but they take it
back they understand what it's being
used for and it's only been used for
that one piece and this is where we talk
about open banking to open finance to
Smart data it is really about that it's
sharing your data so you get a really
great experience and then you bring it
back and you have your time limits on it
and that's what's really important
what's going to come through with the
data perform bill is to give this
Panacea of smart data we've seen this in
other countries it's smart data
legislation that is going to protect
that we're then going to have a huge
issue around education or when when
people are going to use that or not but
over time we have to build up the trust
in this so we're not just worrying about
data breaches we're giving the control
back to Consumer and the business and on
that point about control that how much
control do people have if they want to
use fintech if they want to use these
apps if they want to use this more Savvy
version of Bank thinking do you get to
say actually I'm going to draw my line
here this is as much as I want to put
forward obviously there may be
ramifications for how much you can get
back but to what extent do people really
have that control over their data I mean
I think every company kind of wants to
gather as much data as possible and
that's their starting point and so some
will be really strict in saying you have
to meet this this and this we have to
remember in some practices there are
certain bits of data as a regulated
company you have to gather you have to
have this information and so you need to
think carefully about the proliferation
of that data and how many accounts
you're going to open I speak to some
people who have opened a bank account
absolutely everywhere they're chasing
deals and all these kinds of things that
has a consequence again you're giving
away information so you need to think
about that a little bit more
um but but I think the the smart
providers will understand that this is
is a consequence and at least they'll
educate people about what you're going
to get back in return from this so if
we're doing a retirement planner we're
going to help them understand I can't
tell you what your future retirement
might look like unless you tell me how
old you are today and how much income
you need but I don't need your National
Insurance Number And if someone starts
asking if you're a National Insurance
number then you need to put your alarm
bells and a lot of this is going to come
to education and I'm really amazed
actually you know you get the some
people at one end who are really worried
about everything and and they they won't
delete they'll delete everything and
they're sort of the the I guess the same
people that have been worried about
Security in lots of different ways we
get other people who will just send you
like we get unsolicited emails coming to
us sometimes with just a whole list of
someone's assets and background which is
really helpful because then we can have
a really thoughtful conversation with
them but it's amazing to me sometimes
that they've just deliberately delivered
all that information to an email address
right and and that's that's an
interesting question about it again it
comes back to where use technology
should be doing this in Secure messaging
systems all of those kinds of points as
well so thinking a little bit more about
when you give that information and
providers being better at saying this is
what you're going to get back this is
your reward because actually there's
value to the information you've given it
we're going to take some value from that
so I'm going to give you something for
that value just a reminder to our
viewers at home and in the office you
can submit your questions in the big
Tech Xbox on spectator TV they'll come
to us in real time I'll put as many as I
can to Charlotte and Matt and we already
have some coming in which is great this
is another question that was submitted
before we sat down today just asking
because I've never been 100 sure but how
do fintech companies make their money
and is it different to normal wealth
managers is it through data mining Matt
maybe on the same topic this one's for
you well so for us we we make our money
in the same way as a normal wealth
manager so we charge a fee for managing
Investments if you want to do that's a
percentage charge it's much lower than a
traditional wealth manager that's where
the technology has helped us and for
advice we charge for a fee when you need
that advice so technology in that
business model is is all it's doing is
helping us do it in a way where it's
more transparent and lower cost there
are other business models out there
where they make their money in different
ways so
um you might do Securities lending on an
exchange traded fund and that's how that
provider can give a much lower cost of
for their fund you might have something
similar in some of these free trading
setups as well where they're providing
liquidity and that's a way that they're
going to make make money from it so you
have to be careful and constantly I
think go back to that point I made
before there is nothing for free if
you're getting a service for free you've
got to question that I mean it's been a
question in my mind about banking in the
UK for a long time if you get this ever
supposedly for free but you are going to
pay for it elsewhere and that's it and I
think so you know I think there's
there's new Revenue models that might be
great and they might really work for you
as a consumer but you need to be
cautious about those different parts so
again it goes back to this idea of that
there's a whole range fintech doesn't we
can't give you one answer to that
question we're quite traditional in the
way we charge other providers might be
quite different right well let's move on
to something we've been talking around
and you know let's just address it the
role in in ever digitalized world of
financial advisors Charlotte have they
become a luxury rather than a necessity
um and I think well I think it's it's
again it becomes different to to how
you're going to interact some are very
very confident and don't trust the
humans they say well actually I want to
have much more information on my
fingertips and we use everything online
other people want to sit and take all
that information but then go and speak
to someone right and get that advice so
they take control others want to
Outsource the whole decision
and so I think it's it becomes where
where people are comfortable and where
do they personally need the help and we
do have to be careful and we've all
talked about during the pandemic of the
older population who didn't have access
to many times online or weren't
comfortable using it and suddenly found
that that person had gone away
um you know I mean we were in the race
for technology we mustn't forget that
they're we're not excluding people I
haven't talked about financial exclusion
not Financial inclusion
um but in terms of your advisors
is a luxury no it's not luxury it's
whatever you need it to do for you to
help you understand it and then the the
beauty we have now is there's
information out there that you can get I
would encourage everybody to go and find
more information about it to make sure
when you're sitting there making that
phone call well why are they advising me
on that you know what's their return you
know what are they charging me
um and is that the best deal I have so I
think yeah what we're going to probably
see for some time is that perfect
intersection really where there's more
information if you wanted
um but if you're not comfortable with it
and you need someone to talk to you
still need to have that person there and
I think that is going to be important if
we're going to bring everybody into into
this new world and it's a bit like the
access to cash debate a lot of people
say we must continue to have access to
cash a lot of other people are saying we
must have access to cash but we've got
to help people in the transition away
from cash and other people say why do I
you know why do we should we accept cash
at all because again we're at that we're
at that strange sort of moment at the
moment especially in in in with
financial advisors where they have you
from some people an incredibly important
role
um and you know they've seen that it's
an absolute necessity whereas for others
they just use them quite wisely to
challenge what they have and then go and
get that final piece of information as
well from you know from the person that
perhaps they want to hear from that they
can phone up
one can never know just how far
technology will advance and maybe it
really will be the case that these
algorithms and these apps can do equal
if not more than what a financial
advisor can do but for now there does
seem to be a bit of a sweet spot if
you're if you're in a position to do it
where the fintech is helping you have
more access in real time to to the
information you want but that human
touch that human advice which is still
much more creative is is going to be
beneficial and I think it's about
picking and choosing when you need it so
what we find is that a lot of our
clients don't use advice on a day-to-day
basis so the business models change
there that's something to firstly be
aware of traditionally what advises or
what a businesses did is they force you
to have a vice pay for this ongoing fee
for this great service I'm going to give
you and actually people didn't need it
most years the advice will stairs you
out what we want to do is have to pick
and choose it when you need it and it's
not about demographics necessarily it's
it's there's people that want advice
that are young there's people that don't
want advice that are old it's about
turning points in life so when you're
going to pay off your mortgage or when
you're going to about to retire most
people at that point want a conversation
in into some degree at that point that's
why there's still call centers at Banks
and things I can do everything online
but sometimes you want to speak to
someone and I think making sure you have
that access is really important and I
think sometimes just to sense check it
so you may have got all the information
read it all made your decision we have
loads of calls with clients that say I'm
thinking about doing this is it the
right thing and then in complex areas
particularly so let's say you're
thinking about retirement and you've got
your lifetime allowance around your
pensions as well well to consider that
might be a moment where it's just worth
sense checking before you do something
that can make a big difference to your
outcome and that's probably worth paying
for as well I think that's the other bit
we should get to sometimes paying for
that makes a lot of sense what you don't
want to do is pay for services you're
not using or pay too much for services
that aren't giving you the value back as
well and what we had pre fintech was all
the banks were centralizing they were
doing everything I can do it all for you
and they were charging a healthy fee
along the way for each different part
what you need to do is disaggregate that
and that's what fintech really helps and
said okay this is the right thing for
payments I don't need advice about that
I can do that this is the right thing
for my currency conversion this is the
right thing to pick my insurance but if
I'm going to do a mortgage maybe I want
to speak to a mortgage broker if I'm
going to talk going to draw down maybe I
want to talk to a financial advisor
being able to pick and choose that's
what we should be using for and if those
humans use technology to drive down the
cost of their service and increase their
efficiency then we should that's how the
virtuous circle comes that's how we get
the better outcome from all of this we
can't have a conversation about wealth
management and personal finance today
without talking about the big elephant
in the room inflation the prospect of
rising interest rates and the fact that
things are not stable right now they're
they're constantly changing and
Charlotte in this current very volatile
economic climate with the cost of living
crisis inflation Rising the prospect of
further Rising interest rates how
susceptible is are these fintech
businesses models to these massive
changes that are happening very very
quickly well and I think it's you just
taking a step back on your question
there it's also you know what's that
going to mean to people who have got
such so used to it yes ultra low
interest rate environment and have never
lived through a high interest rate
environment yeah um no I you know I grew
up in a very very high interest rate
environment
um and as a result one when even at the
age of 16 when I went down to the local
town and chose the logo that I wanted
and walked in to see the bank manager
like you could back then
um and you sentencing how much are you
going to pay me for my current account
how much am I going to get my interest
rates are amazing right I get free money
plastic and then when it came to taking
my first mortgage he was so careful
again that they still because it was you
these were not you know these were not
point one percent these are Big figures
three four five percent you know my
first mortgage was eight ten percent
yeah
um yeah so so for those of us who've
grown up with that background I think
we're much more attuned to this what
worries me is a lot of people have never
done that and have not seen this coming
um they haven't seen the cost of living
their own up they haven't experienced a
higher interest rate environment
um and this isn't the days where you
could make a bit of money in your
current account you know to sort of
offset perhaps you know some of those
there's increased bills because we're
not really seeing that now
um to your point you know what we're
seeing is obviously the banks can't just
get you know they can't pay the interest
rates down on that and bring their costs
down here and make less money so what
you're seeing is obviously those
interest rates are still coming there
but guess what mortgages are going to
potentially go up
um so I think it's it's again this comes
around education and is this the pivotal
moment for fintech to actually say this
is when it really does come into its own
how can you make that every penny work
for you
um so this this summer you know from
banking we're bringing in something
called sweeping and sweeping which again
allowed a lot of people to within their
own their own bank this will allow
people to get paid into one account and
sweep automatically or the predetermined
time or a predetermined amount into
another account convenient right really
convenient
um you know and it's not this isn't this
isn't simple uh this isn't this isn't uh
complicated it's really easy
um now we have had something called vrps
which is variable recurring payments
which will put everyone off but when you
look at it it's you know why wouldn't
you get paid your sign up into one
account and then automatically
transferred or transferred however much
you want to into a higher interest rate
paying account you know in in Australia
a lot of people use offset mortgages not
what he used to offset mortgages so
people have this effectively as dead
money sitting in account that's not
doing anything right the banks probably
don't want it either they're not making
any money from anybody so I think we've
got to get people
formed
over this and I wonder as we go through
what's invertedly going to be you know a
tough winter
um with increased energy increase
interest rate environment that how can
we use this moment to help educate and I
think the best fintechs will be the ones
who make that user Journey really easy
and what we have to be a little careful
of which comes back to your comment on
financial advisors is that you know
who's educating the Educators as well is
every financial advisor completely Savvy
on on what's out there and offense to
anyone in the audience is a financial
advisor but you we have to make sure
that they understand it and are they
giving the best advice because some of
them again won't have grown up with this
either but this is this is the moment
for fintech to shine you know making
sure the rate the information is
available but also just make sure people
don't use those decisions to quickly
move between right if they're then
looking up their finances to something
where they don't realize they're doing
it right and so I said education is key
for me and you know I personally love
the fintechs you spend loads of time on
that you user Journey looking at the
interface forward giving people the
information but making it really simple
and I think that's you know that hopes
will be the ones that went out Matt
Charlotte points out there that there
are now generations of people who are
not used to the concept of rising
interest rates and a lot of these people
will be in their late 20s 30s 40s that
maybe they've bought their verse home
um you know they're looking to
renegotiate their mortgage they're not
people who you know the biggest purchase
anyone's usually ever going to make is
going to be their home they're very
sensitive about it but they're also new
to this what kind of advice would you
give them I think it's really good time
to take a step back and think about all
of your goals what you're trying to
achieve you're right this is an
environment as well that I think even in
investing loads of people haven't been
through it and even older people that
they've started investing thinking about
their pensions maybe it was done by
their companies they've moved into it
they sat in an environment where
basically whatever you bought went up
pretty much and they thought I'm an
absolute hero I'm good at this I know
what I'm doing and now they're starting
to experience that and we're finding
lots of people coming to us saying I
don't don't know what I'm doing and I
need some support there and I think what
we need to do is take a step and think
about those goals those objectives and
how to balance it so you're going to
feel your mortgage price is going to go
up and that's going to be painful but
what you need to make sure is that what
you don't do is sort of Rob Peter to pay
pull and you don't stop making pension
contributions because that's going to
have a big impact on that other goal
it's balancing these things that really
matters and you need to decide is it
some of your discretionary spend it's
some of your savings that need to go how
do you balance those different parts and
and I think fintech can help with that
advisors can help with that it is about
education people understanding those
choices where technology can come in is
it can visualize that trailer for you so
if in our retirement planning tools for
example I can say to you look if you
turn your pension contributions from 300
pounds a month into 100 pounds a month
in order to pay your mortgage this is
the impact this is what it's going to
cost you in 30 years time that's pretty
powerful because it in 30 years it will
be a big number that it will be and you
can make a decision about that you have
choices they may be tough choices it may
mean moving to a less expensive house it
may mean not going on holiday you know
those choices will have to be made but
at least you can make them in an
informed way my fear is that people will
just see the thing that shouted the
loudest that's put in front of them you
know as a world we're not very good at
giving a balance Fuel and every every
information we talk a lot about the
thing that we should worry about energy
bills or so on um we need to think about
it all and what we don't want to do is
find that there's all these unintended
consequences that kick in later on it's
a choice present information to them
help them make an informed decision just
a reminder to viewers at home and in the
office that you can submit questions
through the text box on spectator TV
they're coming through to my colleagues
live they're being funneled on to me and
I'm going to put as many as I can in
about 10 minutes to Charlotte and Matt
so we we have about 10 minutes before I
really want it to get into some of those
meaty questions
um before we do that though Charlotte
we're talking a lot today about the
democratization of personal finance and
you were talking earlier about some of
the biases that are built in
um and I want to talk a little bit more
about digital divides so in many ways
it's fantastic that the individual has
all of this information at their
fingertips on their phone all the rest
of it um but there are people who have
traditionally been excluded from
investing
um and as we democratize uh who are the
people we really need to be looking out
for and what areas do you see still that
need significant Improvement and yeah
and there are people who don't even have
a bank account and they'll be educated
you don't have access to the internet
right Amazon's race for technology we
have to remember that as well
um that we have to find a method to look
after this as well
um you know later statistic and mine
will be out of date now was 12 million
people in this country have less than
100 pounds in their account
um I mean that's just a starting number
and if you think of these your energy
bills that are now coming through and
you want to fix your race but it's
incredibly at a much higher rate yes
yeah because you know to offset the risk
over the winter a lot of people just
don't have that choice in front of them
Unfortunately they can't do it so it's
the short-term gain they can't they
can't even think about what might happen
next
um so you know when I will sit there and
you know nearly all day every day I'm
working with fintech providers that are
looking at speeding this up and some of
them obviously do you know incredible
work in financial inclusion I think we
do have to just remember that we've got
to help every single one of those as
well as the ones obviously who are then
looking and planning their retirement as
well
um you know and this is where Auto
enrollment is so good it's just sitting
there allowing people to start thinking
about the saving for that
um you know we look at the gender gap in
in pensions where people take a career
break and don't think about it and don't
say for their pension I mean that can't
be right it cannot be right
um so when we when we think about
democratization it's across everything
it's the bias into the system
um yeah based on past data so I said
it's life it's life instances like maybe
having having a child or taking a career
break or looking after a sick parent
um and it's also about you know as I
said bring bring the new generation
through who are really tech savvy but do
they really understand that that
decision they make now is going to have
these Untold consequences to the Future
and and also importantly for you know
maybe the older generation who haven't
been this tech savvy as they as they
want to be
um and don't really understand it and
making sure that when they're talking to
someone that they're making informed
decisions as well so I think you want me
to talk about democratization we've just
got to consider everybody along that
Spectrum not just the people who have
got you know huge amounts of investment
wealth transfer and looking at that for
the next you know their children but
actually looking at it as a whole and
saying are we actually doing the very
best for each of those Generations
within you know within the different
groups and different socioeconomic
groups and let's just make make sure
that we try to level up the education of
that
so that when we come to the Next
Generation we've set ourselves in the
right base Matt I think you're
completely right and it's about how you
solve that problem and what I have seen
and what's worked really well with
fintex is when they focus on a specific
area a specific problem a specific
demographic they're designed for that so
if you want to work with older clients
you need to design a completely
different way to a 20 year old who might
be tech savvy if you want to work for a
20 year old it's not tech savvy it's
completely different to the one that is
so you know that's what you need to
think about and solve those problems
where we'll get it wrong is if we try
and get one institution to solve it for
everyone they'll end up with something
that works for no one and this is about
how you design whether you use desktops
so older Generations generally a more
desktop Savvy when they make decisions
and deal things mobile for others but
that's an assumption that's made that's
a bias that we're already making we have
to think about the specific parts and
the problems that you're trying to to
solve there if we get that right and
fintech can definitely help in that area
then we'll get we'll get good solutions
for each of the individual problems and
we'll bring everyone up the real area
that might fall out in that is those
that when there isn't money to be made
from helping them that's where
government needs to step in and help and
support those specific areas so that
might be education it might be providing
more access to digital tools and and
even computers and mobile phones and so
on to people that need access to that in
that environment we need to think about
those people of course because in
reality fintechs most of them are trying
to make money for their shareholders
that's what they're trying to do and
they're not probably going to be focused
on on areas where they can't do that so
it might be charity it might be
government but we need to think about
how we can do that as a group how we can
educate people that's the job of the I
guess the industry as a whole rather
than one individual company and that
safety net is always important because
whether it be in fintech or education or
Healthcare policy in any policy you're
going to have a group of people that
fall through the crack so that's a very
important point to make but I'm I'm
quite optimistic and interested in this
idea that in fintech in particular there
is money to be made by being more
inclusive by bringing more people in do
you have you found that that with your
experience with fintech businesses that
actually you are more optimistic about
the future of banking for those groups
that were historically marginalized when
it came to find Finance compared to
traditional banking definitely so
women's an interesting part for us so
traditional wealth management businesses
have a very poor split between male
female so they have a lot of male
clients and not many female ones we've
around 50 either side 50 50. and that's
partly because of the way that we make
it and more intuitive for them more able
for them to understand it so we often
have conversations with female clients
to say look that's the first time I've
actually understood but the first time
someone's spoken to me in a way where
they're wanting me to understand it
rather than saying don't worry I'll deal
with your finances over here we'll take
care of it and I think that's a starting
point that's great for us that means we
get more clients that's 50 of the
population out there that we want as our
clients and I think you just need to be
open-minded to that it's very easy for
the existing incumbents to stick with
the status quo because they're making
lots of money in the status quo and it's
for us to go and challenge that and take
those opportunities but similarly for us
about democratization of investing for
people making people realize that
they're all investing if they've got a
pension they may not think about it and
helping them to deal with that helping
them to make more informed decisions
again your traditional insurance company
that's getting those pension
contributions isn't particularly
incentivized to help people to think
about it they want the money to keep
coming in keep being invested that's how
they make their money we've got to help
open that up and if there's an
opportunity for a business to also make
money from that that's that's how that's
how this should work that's the future
really Charlotte yeah I mean we've
certainly seen that we launching
something called an impact report that
looks at the impact of of open banking
um and it's incredible the statistics
that people say when they have the
information available to them that makes
them more likely to save and it's
increased their savings as well so even
right at that you know the lowest level
all the way to the highest level the
information there the education the
access to that is helping people
understand their money and I think
that's what we've got to really focus on
is help people that
um and that's soon as I said for someone
who's got that nest egg and they're you
know planning for retirement or they're
planning to you know to to help their
child perhaps you know and get a
university or even buy them over their
first place you know let's make sure
they're using it and then let's make
sure we bring up you know they bring up
the teenagers who are pharmacist people
on on Tick Tock and may have a 30 second
video that allows them to make a snap
decision that may not always be the best
either so I think you it's it's it's uh
it's fascinating when you see this that
you know two-thirds of the population is
using these to help them understand how
to save and so in many cases it's
helping to save the first time we've
seen the fintechs who do the top-ups
when you pay something do you want to
just have those extra few Pence and you
put into a savings account and it's tiny
amounts but when you're doing it all the
time because so many people are
obviously using online services to pay
um you know that does add up and I think
you and that's been incredibly popular
for for the younger population
um so I think you anything where we are
bringing the the younger generation with
us on this journey I think is is really
important because they will be the ones
who are much less likely to pick up the
phone and you can imagine you say to a
teenager or you know if you between nine
and one on a Saturday if you're too busy
during the week you can phone someone if
you can't do it after 1 pm on a Saturday
no I'm not going to do that right
they're going to sit there and make that
decision on Saturday night or on a
Sunday and they're going to be using the
smartphone to do that and you layer on
the push notifications that are going to
come in so layer on the influence of
social media that's going to sit there
and uh you know and help them consider
those bins we just got to be really
careful we do that
um and I think it is it becomes quite a
fascinating time but let's really use
that to say this is what Satan does for
you and I think the the problem is you
know in this generation compared to
where I grew up we all grew up thinking
we want to save for our first house
right that's what we wanted to do we
were obsessed about sitting there how
quickly can you save up your deposits
you can go and get a mortgage and
unfortunately now that's just out of the
reach many many people across the
country who want to go on the property
ladder they just can't even envisage it
so what they do is they take their
disposable income and they use it
because they can't see really the Merit
of it so they have the water enrollment
and pension yet tick the Box I've done
my pension there okay I've got a little
bit of savings there that'll pay for my
holiday okay a little bit here I might
get the credit card might use binary pay
later
um and we have to consider that that
this is a very different environment now
and people haven't got used to saving
and they don't understand it so this is
where fintechs can really pay such an
important role by showing them what that
looks like when they save that what does
that mean how much are they going to
have by the you know next year how much
they're going to have for retirement
what happens if they did top up this
much what would that give them and I
think this is where your younger
population will be really responsive to
that
um and you know I think that's when
you've got the power of Technology it's
doing something really good the other
thing you just need to consider is
credit records you know credit records
unfortunately you have a huge role to
play in in the evolution of this but are
not where they need to be now so again
some incredible technology that fintechs
are using to help people build up that
credit score over time to show that
they're paying a bit on Advance
um on time that they're sitting there
and they're maybe paying their rent on
time at the moment that hasn't been
captured historically right it doesn't
you know that doesn't contribute to
their credit score but why wouldn't it
if you're paying your rent on time every
single month it's one of the biggest
extensions you're going to have every
month especially if you're living and
slowly help giving people that credit
score that will allow them then to get a
better deal
um I want to jump into questions and
actually this this first question from
Adam is great because it's an area we
haven't covered yet and I think we must
if we're talking about fintech Adam says
uh do my cryptocurrency investments make
me a fintech expert Mac cryptocurrency
how does this play a role
um I think it's unlikely that it may say
fintech expert because technology the
fintech is as we've discussed is the
technology around it but
um cryptocurrencies um it's it's a
really interesting area the underlying
technology behind it is great
distributed ledgers using the blockchain
that makes a lot of sense it's going to
be used in loads of errors and it's
going to be really really useful the
currencies themselves we don't think
that they play a role in long-term
multi-asset investing which is what we
do we don't think that that at the
moment they are anything more than a
speculative asset
um I think there will be a role for a
digital currency again but it's probably
going to be regulated it's probably
going to be issued by a central bank
again it will that will be helpful but I
think we have I see far too many people
come up to me so I've got my Bitcoin and
I've made you know 30 not many people
talking about it so much right now no it
hasn't been doing as well has it it
hasn't and I think it's not an
uncorrelated asset it has the same
drivers about people interested in
growth in technology and momentum and
these things and I don't think that
necessarily happens when you're looking
to build a portfolio of Investments when
you're thinking about that makes you
looking for the one free lunch there
isn't investing which is diversification
true diversification and so owning ether
and Bitcoin is probably not
diversification in that regards right
right so when we're thinking about
currencies so the dollar has turned out
to be really strong in this environment
because it is still the safe haven
currency we're looking at whether fixed
income is now now offers value those
those sorts of things and I think at the
moment digital currencies you've got to
be aware of what you're going in for
them it's not saving it's speculation if
you want to do that you it can work if
you ride the trends there's plenty of
examples of people that can do that but
you're trading in something you're not
saving for the future and make sure you
get the proportions right about that so
one very different the gamble of the bet
is very different from these are my
concrete savings for my future that's it
and that's what I think that's the value
but they're different that's it and I
think education when I think about well
we talked about educating the younger
generation it's actually quite good for
someone to invest and to lose a little
bit and to see that the impact of that
but we need to make sure it's not in a
scaled way and that it doesn't it
doesn't actually impact on on their
lives as well so we help them do that in
a way that that works that that is
protected well Charlotte youth has some
very insightful comments about the
younger generation and they're
completely new and different experience
with earning and saving and all the rest
of it and what role do you think crypto
is going to play
um I mean it does worry me and I you
know I have a teenager so I I hear her
come home from school and saying so and
so made this and they you know they
bought some crypto and guess what
they're doing this on an nft
um and she's probably more cautious than
most um because she hears me talk about
it
um you know and you know as you're
saying you know it's it is a gamble it's
not regulated it's you obviously the
regulator is now stepping in we're
starting to see the process coming
through but anyone who's reading a
billboard and you see them on the tube
you can see them at Westminster
um right in front of parliamentarians
they're sitting there saying come and
buy this there's this magic pot of money
that you're going to make we just had to
be really really careful
um and I just think you said
particularly the younger generation on
this one and as we go into this winter
coming back to cost of living and people
saying I'm so desperate I'm going to try
that that's a risky place for you to go
um and if you can't afford to lose it
then you have to consider you know how
do we educate those people to say don't
think no just like you know like
gambling that you can put this money in
and that's going to sit there and sort
out your problems because there's a good
chance if you're if you're desperate to
be using that something's gone wrong
um so again you know coming back to my
point it it comes down to how do we use
technology to educate people and what
they're doing and looking at that and
just like when you're toggling between
the portfolio and working out through
what happens when that one goes down to
zero right and you know and does that
matter and is that going to impact on
your others what happens if Equity start
dropping what happens when currency
start moving what happens in
cryptocurrency drops you know what's the
impact that's going to have on your
portfolio and can you afford to lose
that and that's the important piece we
have to we have to look at is really
looking at that unfortunately and we are
slightly going into this at the moment
potentially worst case scenario what
happens when you lay on your household
bills and you sit there and can you
afford a 50 increase in those
um so I think what I want to see is I
said is is a simple user interface I
want to see people sit there if they are
using Spectrum Investments that they
understand it's a really respective
investment
please please don't rely on it um
because there's a good chance for your
alarm and you can't afford to do it
Jim asks how does an older non-technical
person gain digital skills to take
advantage of fintech
I think getting started anyway the fact
that you're attending this webinar and
wanting to talk about come join
spectator TV that's the first point it's
a great starting point though I think
you've got to dip a toe and get
confidence in it because a lot of this
comes down to confidence so I take the
video calls in the pandemics as an
example we found a lot of clients we
offered them a video call and they said
no I can't do that I don't want to do
that when they needed to when they
wanted to talk to their family and so on
they they started to realize that
actually it's it's doable they can make
it happen and doing it step by step by
step we sort with with payments and
online banking and so on again so I
think it's about making small steps it's
not trying to go all the way over here
to this sort of super new app only thing
if you if you don't use a smartphone but
starting on even just communicating by
email and then dealing with someone in a
hybrid way so for example if we have
clients that come into our office we
still use all the digital tools but just
with them and talk them through them and
show them how to use them when we're
when we're going through the modeling we
often have a video call and we get them
to share their screen now that could be
the first challenge whether you can
share your screen on I'm sorry but we
can talk you through the steps and
that's why I think a hybrid approach is
still going to be there for a long time
it's it's all very well having built the
best user experience and a great journey
if people haven't got the basics of that
we need to help get them there over time
and and that will happen you know
because even people who think they're
tech savvy in their 40s and 50s today
there's a whole lot of new things that
are happening with the teenagers that
they they won't be tech savvy on and
they'll be the same person in their 70s
in a few Generations time Charlotte yeah
so it was an incredible statistic that
came out at the beginning of the
pandemic that six million people had
downloaded their online banking app for
the first time in the first month for
the pandemic
just shows how quickly the pandemic
assured such a new way forward when it
comes to technology it was and that's
getting you know that's not going to go
backwards yeah and a lot of that number
is predicted that obviously came from
the older population who had never done
it before who was still used to going in
and paying their checks into the bank
talking to someone at the bank window
you know and then going back again
sometimes that was their daily visit
that's what they did
um so if there's a good thing that's
come out of it you know they don't have
to do that anymore
um but of course the impact of that is
some people still want to do that as
well and what do we do and we've seen
this incredible Innovations where the
banks have come together saying well we
can't all have
um you're a bank branch open in a
certain town it's just not cost
effective the time pressures on that on
our margins and they've come together
with these Bank hubs where people can go
in and still have that face-to-face
contact you wouldn't it be great if they
use those and then have a maybe a
digital lesson at the same time
um you know yes it's great for the
fintech to be able to do it is it
fintech's responsibility to educate
everybody across the country that's not
additionally Savvy to take them to this
level or has there got to be some sort
of program on that so I would love to
see you know for those who want it and
want to be online and want to be able to
understand their money in more details
and don't just want to wait for that
quarterly statement to pop through that
pop through the letterbox to be able to
sit there and and have that access and
find us at that hybrid there
um anyways they've managing to get their
online shopping they manage them to get
their online banking they're managing to
do zoom and teams calls and it's
incredible really we never would have
seen that I think happen so it's
accelerated this opportunity but let's
not sit there and say okay now we're
going to leave them on their own it's
all fine let's give them those tools now
to just build a little bit so Silver
Surfers for anyone knows Silver Surfers
you can go out and you can you can be a
Silver Surfer and go and go and
understand how technology works but
let's build in the financial education
that we still don't really provide
automatically in this country right um
and give them those tools to then evolve
from that
uh Lou says I'm looking to consolidate
with a local wealth manager but how do I
check on their adoption of fintech what
are the right questions to be asking
when you're looking uh shopping around
shall we say for a local wealth manager
I think you start by opening plainly
about what do they use in terms of
technology for transparency of
information so a local wealth manager
are they going to help on board you with
paper forms or in a digital way are they
ask them to see what it looks like when
you're a client as well I think far too
many people actually know what the
experience is going to be because
they'll talk to you all about the
planning elements and your finances and
they don't give that information ask
them how they're thinking about the
future of technology as well because
where you are today is not where you're
going to need to be in the next step and
I think that's a big challenge for ifas
individual providers we've seen them do
a little bit of moving already so
historically an IFA would be your
financial planner they'd probably pick
your Investments for you as well then
they do your reporting back to you and
that's Andy admin and and really what
they've realized is that they probably
can't do the Investments themselves now
so they've outsourced a lot of it to
just discretionary managers investment
managers they probably shouldn't be the
ones doing the technology as well so
what platforms are they using who are
they working with as a provider one
individual in your local town probably
isn't going to be using the latest
technology in every setup but are they
using the right things it's not about
getting again all the way to that
perfect solution but are they thinking
about it are they dealing with it or are
they saying this doesn't bother me
because I'm only going to be doing this
for another 10 years and then I won't
have to adopt technology and we do see
that from a lot of firms a lot of
advisors say I don't need to worry about
this it's all good I'll just carry on
with my clients you've got to find
someone who's a little bit more
thoughtful about that Charlotte what are
the red flags
um I mean what I'd say yes think about
maybe beyond your local wealth manager
and you know and I mean the one thing
that's taught us in the pandemic you
don't need to go and see them face to
face you can do video calls you can go
further afield and and make sure that
you're getting a range of opinions on
that
um so if you're choosing one I think
it's good enough I'll put up with it
have you really done your research have
you talked to other people have you been
to online forums trust Pilots you know
it's quite interesting when I you know I
often look at this and say what you know
what are people saying if there's only
10 reviews you know there's a good
chance it's not going to be
representative and good chance they'll
be some 10 people who've probably got
upset with it and have bothered to put
it in but many of these have thousands
and thousands of reviews online
um so go and do the research and really
think about it before you make that
decision and then as you said you know
look at the technology they're using and
does that work for me because some of it
might be great technology it may just be
too advanced and that suits some people
that's that Niche Point others might
want a really simple user interface and
that you know that particular fintech
works better for them
um so I think that's important do do the
research look around shop around and
make sure that you said it suits you and
where you are Charlotte we have a
question in from Sarah who is listening
to your comments saying I'm still
worried that women can get a worse deal
when it comes to wealth management how
do I prevent that and what more needs to
be done oh I mean goodness we haven't
got long enough I mean yeah and I
totally agree with you so
um you know it's it is scary the the
bias that is in the system and not just
the biases that that is done from from
AI but just through unfortunately when
you go to ifas they will consider a lot
of the time that they haven't had the
multiple class they haven't had the
earnings potential that we've seen
um you know we're obviously both you
know we're based here in London is very
different than the southeast to certain
parts of the country as well where that
divide unfortunately can be a lot worse
and so if you learn in socioeconomic and
the app as well I think I always find
astonishing with with women versus men
there's a really good chance and I'm you
know please don't shoot me down for
being passed here and making assumptions
but in many households the women are
making the uh managing the household
finances they don't they're doing the
energy bills they're looking after kids
they're paying for their school trips
they're buying the uniform they're
sitting there
um and they're making really really big
decisions and then when it comes to
things like pensions and Investments
they're not why is that so they actually
are much more financially savvy than
anyone would consider
um so I find it quite sad that we're
sitting here and still getting a worse
deal for women when actually they're
more than capable to understand that and
they're doing it everywhere in any way
so I'd say to any woman out there you
don't be scared if you said it comes
back to doing your research go and find
that provider that's got a really good
proportion of of female clients and I'll
ask them that question they've only got
five percent female clients go and find
someone else and challenge it challenge
year why you've got that if it's a
credit score you're not happy with go
and challenge why that is and make sure
you're really making a fuss about it
um so education you know knowledge is
power and I think that's that's
important yeah we we're all sitting
around the fintech table and it's not
the most diverse bunch of people either
it's only less than 30 of people working
in fintech are female
um you know one percent of VC investment
um going into Tech firms is going to
female Founders so we're not
unfortunately fixing this problem where
you know it's it's getting worse and
worse graduate level 50 are going in so
what's happening is as women come
through the career ladder particularly
in Tech and finance they're not sitting
there progressing on to management
decisions unfortunately in many cases
and that I do find personally very
frustrating because I've been talking
about it for far too long
um and we've got to change that so you
go and sit there challenge it start off
into it be brave go and solve the
problem every day I sit and think of a
fintech I'm going to start
um John says when it comes to training
there are Financial gaming apps that are
available are these of any value Matt
I think they are going to help you think
about some of the trade-offs and and the
biases that can be there so I think they
can also help you understand some of the
risks so if you're using it to say model
trading for example to understand that
that's a great way as a junior investor
to begin with I remember doing one at
University where I was building a
portfolio and you've realized quite
quickly if you put it all in one stock
and it doesn't go up you're in trouble
right diversification is an education I
think there are lots of ways we can help
you have to get people engaged to want
to want to use them and and those parts
and it's again back to that knowledge is
power information can we do it in
engaging ways though so I think that the
games can be helpful for that engagement
part because Finance personal finance
for the vast majority of people in the
UK just turns them off they're not
interested in it that's the reality
super important it's relevant to
everyone but they're not interested in
it so can we find ways to make it
interesting to bring people into the
fold so that they can make more informed
decisions for things that really matter
in the future so gamification is an
option that lots of fintechs think about
when they're building information how do
you get people to engage a bit more how
do you get them to to think about their
savings goal or so on as long as that's
being done for the the right purposes
and you get the right outcomes you don't
accentuate biases as well because that's
the other thing that can happen in these
you can teach people to make the wrong
decisions but assuming that's that's
working correctly then I think they can
be really helpful
um we have about five minutes left so I
want to finish on a fantastic question
that's come through
um uh from Jay who says I want to ask a
broader more existential question is the
democratization of Technology entirely
helpful is there such a thing as too
much information Charlotte what do you
think
um I think there is yes
um and I saw this recently when I was
looking at um said back back to uh doing
some research in particular fintechs I
was looking at and I saw someone just
had all this information it was pension
provider and sat there again these
people a terrible review and said look
what's happening look what's happened to
my investments today yesterday they did
this yeah and the day before they did
this and they were trying to make a
decision do I now exit from those with a
penalty fee based on the last week's
performance gosh such a short period of
time that's you and you know and I hope
so when you look at young people who've
got you who are unfortunately are making
these decisions based on really really
small amounts of information and a very
short time period for decisions that are
going to last 20 30 years sometimes
that's just a bit too much information
so yes is it great to have information
great to have technology in front of you
great to have a great user interface but
let's just make sure that we sit there
and say you know again back to the
tooling that this is what's going to
happen don't make a quick decision there
I think that's the only thing that
worries me a bit can you imagine the
push notifications that come through
saying guess what your Investments did
this today right they've outperformed
these other providers by this and you
and those ones maybe can allow you know
be allowed to to advert ties and
somebody makes that quick decision there
so let's just find a way to protect
against the short-termism because I
think that's the biggest risk we have
no context is key um so the reason we
decided to build a hybrid wealth manager
is that the human can help give context
so we can try and put context around
information so we can try to help you
understand if it's doubt or in our app
for example where the portfolios are
shown the total return we show whether
you're in a normal range and that normal
range has negatives and positives
because in every investment there's no
ranges and it changes on time periods so
if you're in a less common or an extreme
outcome as well but then we've got a
human there to ask so if someone says
Okay I want to sell out of my portfolio
they can have a conversation first and
we can then just help them think through
the different choices make decisions if
I gave them a bunch of tick boxes online
that's probably not going to help them
yes I've signed all the statements I
want to get out but you can explain to
them why it matters or the context of
the markets around them I don't think
technology is ever going to solve all of
those different parts to give the exact
right context to the right person at
that moment you need to talk to them and
find out so why are you worried about it
are you worried about it because you
were planning to use this money to buy a
house in in two years time and it's down
five percent okay but actually that
might still be okay perhaps the best
thing to do is to sit away or maybe the
right thing is for you to sell out
because you shouldn't have been there in
the first place so I think it's about
giving information giving context and
using humans when it's the right to help
interpret that information and dare I
say point out the most important
information in what is just an unending
um you know list of data that you can
access now exactly so I don't think we
should Reign back the amount of
information we're not the right people
to decide where how much information
should be but we've got to keep being
better at giving more context helping
people and keep giving easy access for
people to get that help and support
along along the way yeah well that's all
we have time for today if you missed
some of that live discussion the full
podcast and video will be up on the
spectator channels next week and if you
still have unanswered questions please
send them to Matt and his team by
visiting their website they would be
very happy to answer those for you a
really big thank you to net wealth again
for sponsoring today's discussion and
making it possible to do this on
spectator TV and a special thank you to
Matt and Charlotte for a year amazing
advice I'm Kate Andrews we so appreciate
you tuning in this afternoon and we hope
that you'll join us again next time
[Music]
foreign